when i was in my early teens
i stood up all night writing a
screenplay when you're trying to get the
words on paper and your three thoughts
ahead of yourself and it's a race to get
it all down before it goes back to where
that's ever that stuff originally comes
from it was called inspiration it was as
close to the feeling of flying as i have
ever had and when i was alone i would
just draw pictures
and i would write little stories
and i would make up little characters
and
you know what i was doing was i was
exploring
a world
that maybe perhaps i could fit into
people all coming together under one
roof to see one story told to them
and they don't know each other they're
perfect strangers to one another and
they probably don't even agree with each
other but somehow
they get into a kind of communal
agreement about the story that's being
told to them and they all walk out
feeling the same way if it works if it's
successful is don't worry so much about
technique and don't worry so much about
where to put the camera or how to light
worry about one thing or think about one
thing preoccupy yourself with how do you
tell a story that's really interesting
that you can get somebody not to walk
out of the room right in the middle of
your second act of you're telling the
story if i had to single out one area to
which i have an utter devotion it would
be with my
preoccupation with the idea
and the fight to still believe in the
idea when so many others around you just
don't get it and the challenge of
staying interested in one single idea
for sometimes years
and the struggle not to contaminate
that idea after months and years of
obsessing over it
[Music]
[Music]
so i didn't really prepare
anything
at home the night before so let me just
talk a little bit about
about something i said you know when a
journalist asked me
years ago a question i really couldn't
answer
you know they said what do you what do
you do why do you do this and
and i don't know where it came from but
i sort of turned to the journalists in a
flip flip kind of way i said i dream for
a living
and and and
years later i realized well that's
exactly what i do i dreamed for a living
this is what i've
done all my life this is what i wanted
to do with my life well i hope i've been
doing that all my career i hope i've
been telling stories
my whole career that has you know
brought people together of of of
different ideologies but
people all coming together under one
roof to see one story told to them
and they don't know each other they're
perfect strangers to one another and
they probably don't even agree with each
other but somehow
they get into a kind of communal
agreement about the story that's being
told to them and they all walk out
feeling the same way if it works if it's
successful they all walk out feeling the
same way
so i think film
and the arts are a great unifier
and and and i think i've been doing that
my i think my whole career and the only
only piece of advice i don't have not a
lot of time but the only piece of advice
i love to give is don't worry so much
about technique and don't worry so much
about where to put the camera or how to
light
worry about one thing or think about one
thing preoccupy yourself with how do you
tell a story that's really interesting
that you can get somebody not to walk
out of the room right in the middle of
your second act if you're telling the
story how do you just tell a story that
that that people lean into what you're
saying and they don't lean back they'll
like start looking around the room
find a way first a compelling way to
express your art through your
storytelling once you've got that
there's a lot of people in this world
that will get around you and and show
you the ropes but
learning how to be a storyteller is the
most important advice i can give you
well what you choose to do next is what
we call in the movies the character
defining moment
now these are moments you're very
familiar with like in the last star wars
the first force awakens
when rey realizes the forces with her
or indiana jones choosing mission over
fear by jumping into a pile of snakes
now in a two-hour movie you get a
handful of character defining moments
but in real life
you face them every day life is one
straw
strong long
string of character defining moments and
i was lucky
that at 18 i knew what i exactly wanted
to do but i didn't know
who i
was
i how how could i and how could any of
us because for the first 25 years of our
lives
we are trained to listen to voices that
are not our own
parents and professors fill our heads
with wisdom and information and then
employers and mentors
take their place and explain how this
world really works
and usually these voices of authority
make sense but sometimes
doubt starts to creep into our heads and
into our hearts and even
when we think
that's not quite how i see the world
it's kind of easier just to nod an
agreement and go along and for a while i
let that
going along to find my character because
i was repressing my own point of view
because like in that nilsson song
everybody was talking at me so i
couldn't hear the echoes of my mind
and at first
the internal voice i needed to listen to
was hardly audible and it was hardly
noticeable kind of like me in high
school
but
then i started paying more attention and
my intuition kicked in
and i want to be clear that your
intuition is different from your
conscience
they work in tandem but here's the
distinction your conscience shouts
here's what you should do
while your intuition whispers
here's what you could do
[Music]
listen to that voice that tells you what
you could do
nothing will define your character more
than that i've got to ask you for anyone
watching at home who's you know a young
filmmaker or director or wants to write
or create films what would be your top
tips
well i i can only give advice based on
my own life and what i've experienced
myself
i spent a lot of time alone as a kid i
was a loner
and i spent a lot of time kind of in my
room
and
because i just
felt comfortable that way and when i was
alone i would just draw pictures
and i would write little stories
and i would make up little characters
and you know what i was doing was i was
exploring
a little bit like your cafe i was
exploring a war a world
that maybe perhaps i could fit into
because i wasn't fitting in very well
to the world that i was
you know that i was living in at the
time i couldn't imagine
based on the story that we told that an
audience would tolerate
the just just the amount of of of
violence you know human against human
or inhuman against human and and i i
just couldn't imagine that audiences
would allow themselves to go through
a motion picture recreation of the oscar
schindler story i was very surprised but
as you're telling the story you can't
pull your punches because history is
history
history is history and and if you're
making
you know i i felt that if i'm going to
make you know a story that represents
the survivors and represents the six
million that you know who were murdered
i have to be as close to the reality of
the people that we had interviewed that
told us what it was like for them a.t
was the gift that came from the heavens
for me i was in tunisia
making raiders of the lost ark and we
were setting up a
shot
and i was picking up fossils in the
desert which used to be the bottom of
the ocean millions of years ago and we
were out there in the nephtha desert i
was picking up
and i was remembering
the end of close encounters when richard
dreyfuss goes up into the mother ship
and just before that the little alien
comes down and does the hand signs to
francois truffaut
and it just hit me out of the sky i
thought what if the alien that stayed
behind on earth what if he didn't
whatever it was a kind of foreign
exchange dreyfus goes away and the alien
stays and then suddenly this whole story
hit me like a ton of bricks
and which was really a story about my
mom and dad when they got divorced and
how i felt as a kid
a friend like that to fill the void in
my life and
and and all these things came pouring in
and i actually
put the story together in a couple of
i think a couple of days as this is
obviously based on a
on on the great broadway musical but it
will be
liberally compared to the 1961 film
uh both the 61 film and the broadway
musical both owe a huge debt of
gratitude to william shakespeare and
romeo and juliet so i didn't feel like i
was violating anything because i don't
really necessarily love remakes
but i didn't consider this a remake i
consider this a a reimagined
uh off more authentic and more
contemporary version of the original
musical
but i think this musical has been
performed thousands of times
in community theater in high schools and
colleges
in revivals all over the world in new
york los angeles in tokyo as recently as
a year year and a half ago
and i felt that because it is so
liberally
reproduced again and again every new
cast brings a different interpretation
they may say the same lines because
they're by contract forced to say the
same lines that was originally written
in the 1950s
but they're able to interpret those
lines in a new modern way
if i had to single out one area to which
i have an utter devotion
it would be with my
preoccupation with the idea
and the fight to still believe in the
idea when so many others around you just
don't get it
and the challenge of staying interested
in one single idea for sometimes years
and the struggle not to contaminate
that idea after months and years of
obsessing over it
when i was in my early teens
i stood up all night writing a
screenplay
and felt something to this day i swear i
cannot get enough of
it was as close to the feeling of flying
as i have ever had
you know what i mean when
when you're trying to get the words on
paper and your three thoughts ahead of
yourself and it's a race to get it all
down before it goes back to where that's
ever that stuff originally comes from
and
it was called inspiration
and i actually made a movie from that
script i wrote all night and it was
called fire light
and it was truly an awful movie
but the process was what it was all
about the experience of that obsessive
focus
of having an idea and actually being
able to photograph it
that's been the magic potion for me ever
since you seem to get
very strong performances and
naturalistic performances from your
actors
what's your technique
i don't know if it's so much of a
technique i asked i asked the actor
to
for the most part to to give me too much
so i can then take it down to a level
that i i feel is believable i don't like
casting actors who
are low-key people i like people with
energy so in in the initial casting i
think that half of what a director does
is cast his picture well
and and and the other half is uh is you
know the the control of the people
within that but i think half of the
secret when you do see a good picture
and you like the people it's in the
casting
uh
i i like people who are outspoken and
who are very
large so i can bring them down to life
level i've always said that this is
universal it's been my ancestral home
all these years are the stories true
that used to sneak onto the lot here
when you were a young guy how old
probably about 16. so you couldn't be
tried as an adult at that point no i
would have definitely been taken to
juvenile court
and gotten a suspended sentence for
giving it a good try but i wasn't caught
thank goodness i had a pass for three
days and i just took a chance the guard
will remember i admit i had been here on
three consecutive days
i walked in with no pass the fourth day
and he waved me through and it was that
way for the next three months of my
summer vacation really how i spent my
summer vacation just coming and what
would you do
i would just watch television shows
being shot i would go all around a lot
watching the kind of coordination on the
set
just watching everybody knew what they
needed to do and they did their jobs and
it was very much like
a kind of team sport did you see any
filmmakers that you admired hitchcock
but i got thrown off that set for
exactly i was on the torn curtain set
for about 10 minutes before
someone came and told me to leave did
you get to see him and got to see his
[ __ ] and julie andrews got kicked off by
a third a.d
just show me your papers
why are you here and i said i'm just
here to watch and they said well no this
is a closed set and that was the end of
it youth can really bring change and
this film i felt very strongly
it addresses
the youth it's it's a conversation of mr
spielberg with the youth straight
directly it is it's a direct a
conversation and dialogue with the the
the young people all over the world
today
and we all we intended that to be a
conversation with them i also feel that
it's this generation that's going to
determine the fate of all of us and it's
it's how they're influenced and what
influences them and if they can start a
conversation with people who are
different than they are if xenophobia
someday can be in our rear view mirror
and not
in in our present day vernacular if
they're cat and i think all of that is
going to be accomplished by several new
generations of young people who really
care about each other and and you know
and i i really feel that the secret
ingredient in all of this is trying to
find
or rediscover empathy so i have always
felt that an incredible dance number in
a musical is just as impressive and
likely just as difficult to pull off as
a big screen action sequence i feel like
you've now proven that you're the master
at both so i'm curious what is the
through line what is the constant for
both a skill you used a muscle you
flexed on action sequences and jaws or
raiders or jurassic park that you also
found yourself using in the big dance
numbers of west side story
uh i wish there was some similarity
between like the storming of the beaches
on saving private ryan omaha beach and
like the for instance the dance in the
gym but there is a there is a remarkable
distinction between the two uh i am not
constrained in an action sequence
by by time by tempe
by
by by
the mathematics of music
um on a musical sequence we are all
locked in
uh
to the measure to the beat to the tempe
what is it 2 4 time is it 4 4 time it's
got to end exactly where it ends it's
got to begin only where it can begin so
in a way scientifically
i'm instead of having this much latitude
i've got about this much latitude to get
everything i want to get in such a small
amount of time because then the music
changes compelling me to change the
angle so it is
and i was never good at math i can't
believe i could actually do a musical
because my father kept saying to me
steve how can how can we get getting you
keep getting c's and d's and algebra and
i said that i don't have your genius
mathematical mind and um and then i wind
up doing a musical which is all about
math but i had a lot of people to help
me i had a great choreography justin
peck tremendous cinematographer janice
kaminski a great art director production
designer um in adam stockhausen and a
great company of actors and singers and
and dancers and justin and so we really
worked as a team this was a this was a
monumental collaboration to pull this
off i think the beginning of my career i
had this wonderful experience and
and the thing i really want to emphasize
is i didn't have a choice
i didn't have a choice
when you have a dream
and the dream
isn't something you dream then it
happens the dream is something you never
knew was going to come into your life
dreams always come from behind you not
not right between your eyes it sneaks up
on you
but when you have a dream
it doesn't often come at you screaming
in your face
this is who you are this is what you
must be for the rest of your life
sometimes a dream almost whispers and
i've always said to my kids
the hardest thing to listen to your
instincts your human personal intuition
always whispers it never shouts
very hard to hear so you have to every
day of your lives be ready to hear what
whispers in your ear it very rarely
shouts
and if you can listen to the whisper
and if it tickles your heart and it's
something you think you want to do for
the rest of your life then that is going
to be what you do for the rest of your
life and we will benefit always been
an emotional quotient in
in every film of yours and is emotion
close to you and
what is the deciding factor
is business more important for you
or the emotional factor in a story
you know the emotional factor in the
story always trump because you have been
breaking the business
barriers very often
but but what what
what what calls to me is not whether a
film is going to make a gazillion
dollars
what calls to me is is there an a a deep
urge in the center of myself
that only that film will release
and and then and then exorcize
and and that's the only condition i'll
direct a movie uh if i'm doing a sequel
of course if i'm doing the lost world
the secret of jurassic park of course i
know that the bar has been raised
because if it doesn't make this x amount
of money everybody thinks it's a failure
and there's that added pressure
of great expectation the indiana jones
series they're not sequels but on all
the other three indiana jones films that
i've directed there's a tremendous level
of expectation and that's
nerve-wracking
but but
the fact that those movies are
successful
and make a lot of money isn't why i
decided to direct sequels to the indiana
jones series what advice would you give
to kids who want to make movies oh it's
a good question because i would i would
tell kids who want to make movies to
make movies
when i was a kid the only way i could
make a movie was borrow money from my
father and
borrow his eight millimeter movie camera
and borrow the money because film was
expensive the film and the developing of
the film was expensive then today you
can take your telephone your your pho
your cell phone you can make a movie on
that
and if it's a really cool movie and it's
funny and it's dramatic or whatever you
can post it on youtube
so it's a lot easier for kids today to
get started and follow their passion and
pursue their hearts you know desire to
be a filmmaker because the tools that
were less available
to my generation growing up are
completely available to yours so there's
no reason why you can't express who you
are through video
spielberg spent 30 million dollars
making 1941 an over-budget sophomoric
attempt at comedy the film was
considered an artistic and financial
flop by both critics and moviegoers and
marked his first and so far only
crashing failure
i was low i was depressed i was not
feeling good what got you out of it
uh starting
just throwing myself back into my work
again and starting to uh work on raiders
burned by the disaster of 1941's
spielberg redeemed himself in the eyes
of the movie industry with the success
of raiders of the lost ark
indiana jones was the hero of raiders he
could he won the lady and got the
treasure and i wanted to be the behind
the scenes hero who brought the film in
for under schedule on her bike what i
find with you is that it's truly what
interests you what it is you want to
know at that point what it is you want
to see and i think it's okay that a
first-time filmmaker
being so inspired by movies and music
videos and any kind of music or media um
can make a derivative film it's okay
that your first videos and your first
attempts at telling a story are
derivative
are obviously influenced by something
that
you know
that you saw last week and you want to
kind of do a version there's nothing
wrong with learning the abcs learning
your craft by being derivative but at
some point you're going to need to find
your natural voice and find a way to
give voice
to who you are and who you are by the
way who you are is original it just is
because you're not tom you're not me and
you're not your best friend and you're
not your teacher not your parents you
are you and because of that you do have
every bone in your body is an original
bone
um it's sometimes trying to figure out
how to express your own original analogy
and that sometimes takes a number of
years to figure yourself out people say
you know gee the movie's really scary
because my imagination saw more of the
shark than you actually showed me well
part of that was was intentional because
i wanted i thought i could scare people
with just the ocean
line and and just the mystery of what's
under the murky water but also the dark
shark wouldn't come out of his dressing
room for months i mean the thing never
worked the shark on jaws works much
better on the universal tour than it
ever worked on martha's vineyard when i
made draws
you